think back to where we started
[Music]
no it's just us need to end this one
this goes beyond loyalty this is about
survival hi everyone is charlie
surprised there was even more new
footage that Game of Thrones Season 8
dropped last night so this will be a
breakdown of that other trailer footage
if you're new to the channel I'm doing
videos all season long be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
another round of that book giveaway
going on all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video so this footage starts with a
Samwell voiceover in John in the
godswood with a very very big reunion
you see him brooding under the heart
tree there with that dour look on his
face and Arya Stark walking up behind
him she's supposed to be there during
that big courtyard reunion so this might
not necessarily be the first reunion
that they have when he first comes back
to Winterfell with Daenerys but
samwell's voiceover says think back to
where we started then John's voice
chimes in and says now is just us the
way they cut the lines of dialogue
together as if they're having a
conversation if it really is coming from
the same scene is a reference to season
1 when they both join the Nights Watch
think about where we started you see
them taking their O's under the weirwood
north of the wall all the other brothers
they join the Nights Watch with them are
dead they're the only ones that are left
but obviously the way they cut the
dialogue over this scene of Jon and Arya
in the Winterfell godswood is more of a
reference to the stark children think
about where we started back during the
first episode where they're all there
together having fun
Arya tries to show them up with her
archery skills and it's all just a fun
family moment with all the stark
children Ned and Catelyn together now
the wolf pack is just Jon Snow Arya
Sansa in bran the moody atmosphere and
the looks on their faces just imply that
they're both trying to reconcile
everything that's happened and how much
they've changed as people since they
were last together like the minute that
they're back it isn't them jumping right
back into that moment at the end of
season 1 episode 2 where he gives her
needle they embraced and they had this
really fun moment because of all the
relationships between this
our children I would say that aurilla
has always been closest to John so you
would assume that when he comes back
it'll be this great reunion moment and
I'm sure that it will but Maisie
Williams did an interview talking about
some of the emotional difficulties that
Aria goes through during the season then
obviously all the drama about John snow
learning the truth about Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen and that just
complicating all of their relationships
when everybody comes back together
there's not really enough in this scene
to let you know whether or not John has
already found out and that's when he
comes to the godswood just a brood and
mull over it tried to make sense of
everything if you're hoping for a really
touching tender moment between the two
of them brother-sister like they used to
be during season what I think that
they'll get a moment like that before
the big battle but when Maisie Williams
was talking about Aria's emotional arc
she said that she's really just trying
to reconcile faceless person aurilla and
everything that she's been through all
the crazy stuff that she's pulled
through a reverse red wedding on the
phrase making all the fray pies that was
one of the funniest lines during season
seven trying to reconcile the hardcore
version of Aria with the Aria that she
used to be the stark of Winterfell
so she's slowly coming back to that she
doesn't feel like that little girl
anymore so she's trying to find her way
back to her relationship with John
Maisie Williams also revealed even
though you don't see the footage of it
in any of these trailers that she would
be officially quote-unquote teaming up
with Sansa during season eight she
didn't say exactly what that meant if it
was literally teaming up to take someone
down or if it's more just Wolfpack stuff
left over from the end of season seven
like the lone wolf dies the pack
survives that was what that whole
Littlefinger Arc was about up at
Winterfell
during season seven so when she says
that they'll team up during season eight
I just assume it's the next step in that
progression the same well voice over
also applies to these other main
characters storylines because they flash
through a couple different scenes like
Cersei in tears
so think about where we started they
flashed to Daenerys with Sir Jorah who
you can see cuz it's much better shot
that we got in the last trailer so he's
behind her here think about where they
started in season one in the pilot
episode with them meeting at Daenerys
wedding to Khal Drogo now they're the
only two left from that original group
are you from my country sir Jorah
Mormont of Bear Island I served your
father for many years God's be good I
hope to always serve the rightful king
sure she has kono she has the blood
riders but she picks all of those
characters up during season six when she
killed the rival cows then they flashed
a King's Landing it's mostly a reference
to Cersei storyline think back to where
we started think back to where Cersei
started in King's Landing in season one
now it's just us because Qyburn is
standing next to her there because Jaime
has left her she's lost all of the
children that she's already given birth
to I know we're all expecting some giant
twists with the unborn child that she
claims to have at the moment but she's
also lost Tywin pretty much everyone
that was close to her during season one
everyone that she trusted the zombie
Mountain I technically don't count
because he really didn't become part of
her circle until after season 5 when
Qyburn transformed him but because the
actual quote is Samwell talking to Jon
Snow and you're at King's Landing it
also brings back memories of Ned Stark's
execution during season one you also
notice in this shot over on the left
here these are Lannister banners hanging
on the walls at the right keep may be
Cersei isn't pretending to be a
Baratheon anymore maybe they will
actually change the sigil of King's
Landing in the opening credits to the
Lannister lion from the Baratheon stag
they did say that the opening credits
got a major upgrade we'll just have to
wait for episode 1 to actually see what
those changes were they also flashed to
a scene of grey worm putting his helmet
on at the beginning of the big episode 3
battle with the White Walkers but he's
still got plenty of unsullied left from
his original group so I don't think that
this reference about think about where
we started now we're the only ones left
really applies to him there's a new
scene of the Dragons flying over
Winterfell from a different perspective
than we've seen before this is them
coming around from the west side
opposite the godswood it's probably part
of that same longer scene where Jon Snow
with Daenerys may be riding dragons
together doing a flyby while Sansa Varys
Davos Tyrion here all look up and
surprise like what is going on I talked
about it in my last trailer video with
that other footage they've all seen
dragons they would not be that surprised
by them they would not be surprised by
Daenerys riding the dragons one of the
few things that would make them look
like this is seeing Jon Snow ride one of
the Dragons so we might actually see him
riding one of the Dragons during the
first couple of episodes but you guys
can let me know I just feel like that's
what they're for sure
with a lot of these scenes the other
really important thing about this shot
yeah it's really cool to think about Jon
Snow riding a dragon but it also gives
you a big wide shot at all the combined
armies camped outside the castle walls
it gives you this big landscape shot to
just show you how big their forces are
there's more Jon Snow voiceover saying
we need to end this war while they show
Jon down in the crypts lighting candles
at one of the statues either Ned Stark
statue or lyanna stark's it's a little
too hard to tell which just based on
this footage or whether or not this is
happening in episode 1 or episode 2 I
would assume with all the episode 1
references to scenes from the pilot
episode that he would visit the crypts
sometime during episode 1 just like Ned
Stark and Robert Baratheon they show the
same scene of Theon ships then you're on
ships with the golden company on board
coming to King's Landing
just teasing obviously golden company no
surprise there but also teasing the
conflict between Theon and Euron that's
a much more personal fight for Theon
this season yes he wants to stop the
army of the Dead but number one on his
list is rescuing you're a Greyjoy from
Euron and killing your on himself I
really do hope that they give you Iran
one of the most spectacular gruesome
deaths that they've ever given anyone on
the show but if anyone's gonna kill him
it should be Theon it should be like the
next step in his characters Redemption
arc he's never gonna reclaim his literal
manhood but he might metaphorically be
able to get some of his honor back by
taking down your on they could do
another shot of the Dragons flying over
the woods around Winterfell they flash
the scenes from the big Battle of
Winterfell then Jaime Lannister
screaming over the top of the walls
shouting orders at everyone they cut in
voiceover from a different Jamie scene
of him saying this goes beyond loyalty
this is about survival which is probably
just a reference to everyone in the
north questioning his true loyalties
is he still loyal to Cersei because
they're gonna be pissed when he tells
them that she double-crossed them and is
not sending reinforcements but we know
his intentions are true his character
has turned a corner he does genuinely
want to help them it's just that given
everything that he's done trying to kill
bran in the pilot the fact that he's
literally and metaphorically the
Oathbreaker is really hard for the North
Jon Snow Daenerys and Sansa to
immediately take him at his word I think
that's really where Tyrion is gonna step
in and help out just in the same way
that Tyrion vouched for Jon Snow when he
first met Daenerys because nobody was
really hot on him when he for
rolled up it's a little too hard to tell
if this is pods standing next to him in
this big shot of the battle just a
little too blurry but this is a new
scene of the interior courtyard as the
battle rages on outside the castle walls
this is the same shot of the hound
trying to get his [ __ ] together amidst
all the fire during the big battle
probably having a big PTSD flashback to
Blackwater this is the same shot of
Daenerys and Jon Snow marching into
Winterfell through winter town from the
south with the unsullied the Dragons the
Dothraki this is another new scene of
the unsullied legions changing formation
into battle I'm assuming that this is
after the White Walkers and the White
Army have crest the horizon have come
within range of them because right after
that you see the scene of the White
Walkers horse walk into frame again they
also cut the Jamie dialogue this is
about survival with that scene of Arya
inside the upper halls of Winterfell
during that scene where it seems like
she's running from some White's who may
have made it over the walls at this
point in the fight the thing about that
other footage that I did a video for
last night too is that a lot of people
actually think that this scene of John
and Daenerys at this fireplace is
happening at Dragonstone and not
somewhere else just based on the
architecture of the actual fireplace
itself it does seem like it could be
them going back to Dragonstone together
but when would they actually do
something like that
would this be before the big battle
after they find out about the truth of
Jon Snow's heritage and they're trying
to deal with it Daenerys maybe just
going back to somewhere that's familiar
to try and process everything or is this
happening after the big battle because I
do think the Daenerys is gonna lose more
of her dragons during the season so
think about all the things that are
happening between her and Jon Snow's
relationship and her trying to process
learning that he's Rhaegar son and then
on top of that later in the season
losing another one of her dragons think
about what she was like after she lost
vissarion now imagine that things are 10
times worse for her so just post all
your reactions about the footage any
Easter eggs that you spotted that I
didn't mention in the video and let me
know when do you actually think that
this scene is happening where they may
or may not be at Dragonstone there may
be another promo or two in the next
couple of weeks but I'll do a video for
whatever footage they drop leave your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below
congratulations Vicky Wu's the giveaway
winner from my last big Game of Thrones
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for that other brand-new Game
of Thrones Season 8 trailer with the
footage and click here for my preview
breakdown from episode 1 in episode 2
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight